touche pas touche pas à mon pote
peut-être avez-vous déjà vu ce badge
c'est celui d'une nouvelle association
qui s'appelle sos racisme et qui a pour
parrain des gens comme costa gavras
michel hidalgo
françoise gaspard ou bien à bernard
stasi son but lutter contre le racisme
en dehors des circuits classiques
s'adresser aux jeunes aient utilisé un
langage direct à longeur sos racisme sos
racisme c'est d'abord une permanence
téléphonique pour écoute et les
agressions physiques ou verbales
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres après
minuit des appels souvent anonymes mais
qui peuvent être un premier pas pour
sortir de l' isolement
la démarche refusé le racisme comme une
fatalité de la vie quotidienne oui
deuxième étape pour ceux qui le
souhaitent une assistance juridique
ici on le dit sans fard le racisme est
un délit
il faut faire appliquer plus souvent la
loi de 72 un langage direct pour la
dernière née des associations
antiracistes qui n'entend pas pour
autant concurrencer ses grandes soeurs
le mrap et la ligue des droits de
l'homme se sont penchées sur son berceau
mais sos racisme a choisi un autre
créneau
même si les phénomènes racistes ont
existé depuis très longtemps il y a
maintenant un certain nombre de jeunes
qui commencent à eux aussi reprendre
l'idée que finalement un arabe ça va
trois arabes bon journée des ja j'ai
incomparable mais lorsqu'il ya trois
familles arabes dans mon escalier
ça fait trop et c'est une minorité
encore mais c'est quelque chose qui est
trop grave pour qu'on laisse passer
pourquoi n'avoir pas rejoint le mrap la
licra ou la ligue des droits de l'homme
on pense que
il ya un certain nombre de jeunes qui
pour l'instant ne ressentent pas la
nécessité ou n'arrivent pas s'accrocher
à ce qui existe comme organisation c'est
pas très mobilisateur peut-être pour eux
alors que si on part de ce qui se passe
tous les jours
là où en vie et bien on arrive
facilement à s'apercevoir que on peut
exprimer le fait qu'on refuse le racisme
sans avoir besoin forcément d'adhérer de
se structurer de façon très précise les
rouleurs de convergence 84 eux aussi
avaient accepté le soutien logistique
des organisations traditionnelles tout
en gardant leurs distances
une raison à cela les jeunes issus de
l'immigration ont pris conscience qu'ils
représentent à eux seuls un poids
politique
en 86 ils seront 1 million à voter pour
la première fois